[Musique]
tous les préfets de l'est du québec se
réunissait déjà aujourd'hui pour
planifier leur soumission aux appels
d'offres totalisant 780 mégawatts
d'énergies renouvelables annoncé hier
par le gouvernement legault selon le
décret 60% des dépenses globales seront
faites pour l'achat de contenu québécois
c'est une manne dont plusieurs
communautés entendent profiter et
l'entreprise lm wind power aussi
d'ailleurs avec nous alexandre boulet
directeur des opérations pour les
amériques de lm wind power
bonsoir monsieur goulet bosso adams et
john ou alors c'est un gros projet là
vous avez une bonne nouvelle hier avec
cette aide de québec d'ottawa pour
agrandir votre usine de gaspé projet de
160 millions de dollars
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
concrètement avec ce projet là
effectivement c'était une excellente
nouvelle pour nous c'est un projet sur
lequel on a travaillé pendant plusieurs
moman plusieurs années on avait vraiment
une vision pour notre usine pour
transformer une usine pour l'adapter aux
nouveaux marchés
et puis comme vous avez 17 ans cela ce
que ça consiste en gros c'est de pouvoir
fabriquer départ de beaucoup plus grande
dimension
puis pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur aujourd'hui nous fabriquons des
parle d'environ 47 mind et suite à cet
investissement nous allons pouvoir faire
des qui les parlent de plus de 100 m ils
vont vous donner c'est ça il ya un
marché pour ça on les retrouve
ou c'est pas là ce qu'on voit c'est que
là dans l'ensemble de l'amérique du nord
le marché de l'éolien est aujourd'hui en
train d'exploser
et puis on a un certain marché pour
notamment au québec on a pu le voir au
départ probablement pas né parle de 100
ma été plus mais il ya un marché au
québec qui revient mais il ya aussi un
marché ce qu'on voit chez notre voisin
du sud ou des balles de plus de 100
mètres sur la côte est ce pourrait être
un marché aussi à venir dans le code
interne notamment de l'éolien qu'on
appelle offshore et là vous serez sur
les rangs j'imagine monsieur boulet pour
les nouveaux appels d'offres là pour les
projets au québec aussi ça c'est toi
qu'on était très content de voir le
retour de léo dit vous savez là dernier
appel d'offres de tête de lionne 9,1 et
puis le en 2021 on parle de notre appel
d'offres 300 mégawatts
c'est une excellente nouvelle c'est là
aussi que la source d'énergie éolienne
le travail qu'on ait fait depuis des
années
finalement nous récompense parce que on
a travaillé très fort à baisser le coût
de revient et d'énergie rennes
continuellement puis c'est clair que
l'éolien sera très compétitif les
gouvernements vont pouvoir le voir par
humaines vous parler au futur monsieur
boulet est ce que celui déjà compétitif
les projets éoliens en termes de coûts
de production de l'énergie
oui c'est ça ce qu'on fait on fait
beaucoup d'exportation puis lorsqu'on
voit ce qu'il est l'ensemble des
gouvernements voit que l'éolien c'est là
sur nrj à venir en concert quatre soirs
où il ya une certaine période ou québec
où on avait un doute mais le aujourd'hui
avec la proche du gouvernement
déjà le dernier l'appel d'offres on
était aux alentours du 6 ou le kilo le
kilowattheure men on peut s'attendre à
de bons résultats encore pour les appels
d'offres à venir
on peut parler aussi du renouvellement
des parcs éoliens où on va utiliser les
parcs existants
et puis on va augmenter la durée de vie
utile de ses parcs là ce qui va nous
permettre à nous lm wind parole de
pouvoir continuer à fabriquer des pales
notamment pour le québec
et là le gouvernement le goût justement
va exiger une forte dose de contenu
lequel on parle de 60% pour l'appel
d'offres d'hydro-québec avec ce bloc de
300 mégawatts dans quelle mesure ça vous
avantage je pense qu'il ya certains
manufacturiers au québec qu'il ya quand
même pas mal
puis de pouvoir on aime chaîne
d'approvisionnement qui est mature au
québec puis je pense que pour nous il ya
moyen quand même de fabriquer tous les
composantes au québec majeur mais il y
aussi la flexibilité ou certains
certains manufacturiers peuvent importer
peuvent amener des pièces où les
exporter aussi ce qui peut permettre de
rencontrer le contenu local
c'est pas évident quand même monsieur
boulet lorsqu'on est un manufacturier en
croissance dans un contexte de pénurie
de main d'oeuvre
est ce que ça vous freine dans votre
développement d'autant plus que vous
vous êtes à gaspé donc en gaspésie est
ce que le bassin est suffisant donc ça
nous force à nous transformer madame
st-arnaud puis c'est la réalité
d'aujourd'hui c'est l'amélioration
continue on implante les méthodes lean
puis de cette façon là ont réussi à
augmenter notre productivité puis
l'investissement dont on parle
aujourd'hui
votre non seulement maintenir nos 380
emplois mais aussi à créer 200 ans puis
la superficie du sinn va pratiquement
triplé ça ça va amener beaucoup
nouvelles technologies de l'innovation
puis c'est la force des québécois on le
voit les québécois dans plusieurs
domaines on va trouver le moyen d'en
arriver à nos fins de trouver le moyen
de baisser nos coûts de geôliers
continuellement comme on l'a fait
l'énergie éolienne dans les dernières
années puis 60 et la preuve aujourd'hui
le secret qu'un appel d'offres qui
revient au québec
oui mais quand vous parlez de 200
nouveaux emplois en plus des 380
existence et de la main d'oeuvre
québécoise si vous allez le chercher à
l'étranger
c'est certain que la main d'oeuvre
québécoise au fait partie de l'équation
on a un pouvoir d'attraction qui est
quand même important à gaspé c'est une
ville qui est reconnue au québec pour
pour la qualité de la vie et puis on ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya
vraiment une embrouille main après une
pandémie ou vers la fin d'une pandémie à
revenir dans les régions du québec taq
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est que
beaucoup de gens qui veulent revenir
donc la main d'oeuvre québécoise ou
faire partie de l'équation
mais je vous cacherais pas qu'on a eu la
chance de pouvoir avoir des travailleurs
étrangers avec nous faut des dernières
années
en fait on a eu 48 travailleurs et
travailleuses qui provenait du
philippines
c'est sûr je dis ça a été une expérience
extraordinaire on doit s'arrêter là
dessus monsieur voulait jour merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là merci pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit